Let's take a look at
the life cycle of APT.
It starts by identifying
the attack target.
For example, the target can be
a automobile or aerospace company.
Then, the attacker will research
about the target, in particular,
obtaining information about a target
organization, that can help the attack.
For example, using network scanning and
analysis, the attacker can learn
the target organization's network, and
therefore, the vulnerabilities
of his network services.
Such as, the possible security
flaws of it's web servers.
And by researching the web,
the attacker can also
learn the organization's C level
executives and their email addresses.
For example, many companies list their
C level executives on their webpages.
And once you know their names,
it is not hard to find their email
addresses by doing some web search.
Then, the attacker code can
develop a method to penetrate
the organization's network.
He can make sure that the attack
will go through, without detection,
by utilizing the knowledge he has
learned about the organization.
For example, the attacker can
exploit a new vulnerability
of the organization's web server.
And since, the vulnerability is
unknown to the security community,
the network defenses at the organization
won't be able to detect this exploit.
Or, the attacker can send a so
called deficit email to the chief
marketing officer of the organization.
It is called, spear fishing,
because the attacker has spent time
learning about the organization and
the individual.
And so,
the email would appear to be legitimate.
Once the the exploit succeeds, now the
APT has a foothold in the organization.
It can then communicate back
to the attacker, for example,
it can accept new malware updates,
receive commands, et cetera.
For example, it can now exfiltrate
valuable data, such as,
the design of a new airplane.
The APT will try not to raise any
suspicion, so that it can go undetected.
For example, he wouldonly exfiltrate
data from the server only,
only when there are other legitimate
network connections, from that server,
to the Internet.
And it does not operate,
on any other server, if that server
is not useful to the current task.
That is, he would keep his footprint,
as small as possible, whereas,
the previous generations of malware,
including bottom worms,
would try to infect as
many machines as possible.
This cycle repeats and continues.
For example, the attacker,
based on information sent from the APT
inside the organization,
now learns that there is another part
of the organization that also
holds even more valuable data.
The attacker now identifies that part
of the organization as a new target,
and this cycle continues.